it's good to be back for a session on
faith democracy and globalization and
this time around as for the session
corresponding session the last iteration
of this course we have as a guest
Nicholas Waltrip who used to teach
philosophical theology here at the
davinier lat the Divinity School and
philosophy department and he's one of
the foremost Christian philosophers
working today and in his last but
fifteen years or so has devoted a great
deal of time to the questions of
political philosophy so I'll make a few
introductory comments the Knicks gonna
come up and then professor Blair so so
democracy and globalization as I've
mentioned before I think that's one of
the really important issues that we are
facing today idea of democracy is
extraordinarily popular world worldwide
even though it's true that there are
many ideas about what democracy is
floating in people's minds when you talk
about democracy and they're even more
kind of differences in actual practice
democratic practices and especially
significant I think for for us is a
liberal democracy which is what we are
concentrating on this this session and
have readings on and it has emerged in
the West as a one way of dealing with
clashes computer created by competing
religious loyalties and it continues
that continues to be one of the abiding
problems of liberal democracy John Rawls
believes that diversity of reasonable
comprehensive religious philosophical
and moral doctrines found in modern
democratic societies is a central
problem for political liberalism to
address let me take my jacket off
because I'm very warm I don't know
whether you are there go thank unique
I'm gonna I'm gonna even roll up my
sleeves and
arakune there we can go so that
obviously becomes a significant issue in
the context of globalization and
increased pluralization of social spaces
and what I want to say is making just
two very simple simple comments 1
comment concerns the our conceptions of
democracy and the other comment concerns
our understanding of faiths and I think
what we need here's a thesis for your
resist I'm sure as you resist it if you
want and I'm sure you will partly here's
what we need I think that we need faith
friendly democracies and democracy
friendly faiths faith friendly
democracies in democracy friendly fades
I will not speak too much about faith
friendly democracies because nick has
written a great deal about that issue
question of at least in certain
conceptions of liberal democracy of
bracketing specifically religious voice
from the public arena and the
consequence of that becomes that people
of faith feel marginalized in the
political life liberal democracy becomes
as one of the theologians has expressed
that theologian who has a knack for
interesting formulations Stan Lee
harvies has expressed liberal democracy
then becomes a secularist ideology then
masks that masks a discriminatory
program for policing what religious
people can say in public now that's over
drawn and it's a caricature but you get
the basic point that he is he's making
that probably isn't that kind of a
setting is probably is not quite right
for democracies and isn't quite right
for religious people themselves it
creates kind of politically reclusive
sectarianism or if you have a majority
more more more robust groups politically
aggressive fundamentalism and I think
it's important for those reasons to have
a religious folks if not for other
reasons also express their opinions
and in public as religious opinions
right and shape public debate in this in
this way now this has all sorts of
question raises all sorts of questions
if we even accept that this is this is
this is desirable and that is for
instance questions whether citizen
really can citizenry engage in
meaningful public debates on central
issues if they come from such wide
diversity of perspectives or can
democratic procedures we do not which do
not rest on something that is common but
rest on particular convictions can they
somehow I'll give legitimacy to the
power of the state to course that's a
very important issue I think let me just
say a few more more words on the
challenges for faith traditions what
does it mean to have something like a
democracy friendly faith traditions and
one way to think about it is to say that
all religions are at the bottom the same
so that all different values that
religions different religions espouse
are in fact all the same some people
think that that's the case I'm not I'm
not fully fully persuaded alternative
position would be kind of those are
limiting position is to say that
religions represent radically different
ways of being human and therefore that
the single polity can not hold them all
together it has to splinter on religious
lines I would suggest that there must be
and that there is a sufficient overlap
in values between between religious
traditions and only if there is such an
overlap can one make religious
traditions kind of democracy friendly
now the other question might be do
religions have sufficient stake in being
democracy friendly exclusive is truth
claims now we come back to the question
that we've been discussing from the
beginning of this course
exclusive truth claims characterized
many religions and the question is
whether those exclusive truth clicks are
compatible with pluralism as a social
project we've had already this debate I
don't need to rehash this debate and I
think that much of success of
democracies around the world in the
context of resurgent religions depends
on whether religions with exclusive
accounts of their own religious life can
somehow also affirmed pluralism as a
social project i would suggest also that
many religions may have good reasons to
embrace pluralism as a political project
project now faith traditions have
practical reasons to adopt to a
situation of social pluralism that's not
the case in all countries in many
countries are still relatively
homogeneous but increasingly it's we
inhabit pluralistic social spaces I
think they traditions may have also
moral motivation to do so the principle
of reciprocity you can formulate it what
you don't want others to do to you do
not do to them that's a silver rule as I
was told right the golden rule is what
you do to others as you want them to do
to you one or the other expressed either
of these expresses the principle of
reciprocity in it in if there is such a
principle of reciprocity which is
robustly embrace right of one religion
to be publicly active insert itself will
also lead to the right of all others
well maybe not all others right there's
a practical problem of high level of
religious diversity right and then the
question is what does it mean to give
equal opportunity to each and all the
religions for state to be neutral with
regard to all comprehensive worldviews
but maybe Nick can address some of these
questions now my third point is that
faith the first one was right that faith
have hates have good reasons practical
reasons they have moral motivation and
third is that
faith actually can change it's not that
fates are these e moveable unchangeable
sets of beliefs and practices but rather
than dynamic formations and the good
indication of that good proof of the
possibility of change is the largest
religious body on the planet which is
the Roman Catholic Church in regard to
this particular issue at Vatican 2 in
the 60s early 60s one of the major
achievements of that second vatican
council was to open up the church to
embrace both human rights and also
liberal some form of liberal democracy
so in conclusion crashing key question
is will democratic theory in practice
change to accommodate religious voices
in the public sphere sphere that's one
side of the question second side of the
question is will faith traditions be
able to positively advocate pluralism as
a political project that's the kind of
faith side of the question and to tie
this with the rest of the course that we
were explorations in the course two
great challenges that we have identified
at the intersection of faith
globalization's are these challenge one
was religions as agents of peace rather
than fermentors of conflict right that's
the piece conflict Nexus of our
exploration of the relationship between
religion and globalization i would say
that successful integration of religious
people into the MacRae attic politic
political process is a precondition for
religions functioning as agents of peace
second challenge was religions as
potentially hopefully humanizing agents
in the processes of globalization now
obviously I think bringing religious
voices to bear on large issues of the
day is essential if we are to draw on
religious tradition traditions to
somehow contribute to humanization of
globalization processes both of these
challenges
I think demand for religious traditions
to have a public a voice in the context
of a pluralistic democracy now I've been
under my time and that's pretty good so
Nick's on oh you're two minutes over
your time okay I dream in this either
thanks very much miroslav